Wir haben einen Kometen entdeckt.
- Oh, schön für Sie.
Er steuert direkt auf die Erde zu.
Dieser Komet
ist ein sogenannter Planetenkiller.
* dramatische Musik *
Hallo, Jack Pop hier.
Jennifer Lawrence,
Leonardo DiCaprio, Meryl Streep,
Timothée Chalamet und Jonah Hill.
Das Staraufgebot ist riesig
im Netflix-Film "Don't Look Up".
Und auch die Story ist cool.
Die Astronomen
Professor Mindy und Doktorandin Kate
entdecken einen riesigen Kometen
auf Kollisionskurs mit der Erde.
Ihnen bleiben 6 Monate Zeit,
um die Menschheit zu warnen
und vor der Auslöschung zu bewahren.
* Er atmet schwer. *
Aber ist das plausibel?
Dass so ein Himmelskörper
aus dem Nichts auftaucht?
Und was würden wir dann tun?
Das klären wir mit der ESA,
den richtigen Space-Nerds.
Oh, das ist spitze.
Wir sahen den Film schon vorab.
Keine Panik, wir spoilern nichts,
was den Spaß am Film nehmen könnte.
Uns geht es
um den wissenschaftlichen Background.
Wenn ihr die Analysen liebt,
helft diesem Kanal beim Abheben.
Drückt auf Abo und die Glocke.
Darüber würde ich mich freuen.
* zartes Glöckchen *
Die Astronomie unterscheidet
zwischen Asteroiden und Kometen.
Die meisten Asteroiden
kommen aus dem Asteroidengürtel
zwischen Jupiter und Mars.
Sie bestehen meist
aus Gestein und Metallen.
Kometen sind Brocken
aus Stein, Eis und gefrorenen Gasen.
Sie stammen von weiter draußen,
aus dem äußeren Sonnensystem.
Sie setzen durch Wärme in Sonnennähe
ihre gefrorenen Bestandteile frei.
Die erkennt man
meist deutlich an ihrem Schweif.
Egal ob Asteroid oder Komet.
Wenn so ein Brocken
in die Erdatmosphäre eindringt,
nennt man ihn Meteor.
Was nicht verglüht,
was auf der Erde einschlägt,
nennt man einen Meteoriten.
Kollidiert also etwas mit der Erde
sprechen wir von einem Meteoriten.
So weit ist es
am Anfang von "Don't Look Up" nicht.
Da wissen wir nur:
Auf die Erde kommt ein Komet
mit 5-10 km Durchmesser zu.
Er wird
wahrscheinlich einschlagen.
Es sind 100%
Einschlagwahrscheinlichkeit.
Bitte sagen Sie nicht 100%.
Und wenn wir
'möglicherweise' sagen?
Aber es ist
nicht nur 'möglicherweise'.
99,78%, um genau zu sein.
Sagen wir 70%
und dann sehen wir weiter.
Ist es realistisch,
dass 2 Forschende
einen großen Himmelskörper finden,
den keiner gesehen hat?
Wenn Sie das sagen.
Im Film müssten wir das
Marvel-Darsteller Rob Morgan fragen.
Er ist dort Chef
der NASA-Planetenverteidigung.
Diese Einrichtung gibt es wirklich.
Hier ist ihr Logo.
Auch in Europa gibt es so etwas,
nämlich bei der ESA.
Das Planetary Defence Office.
Dort arbeitet Detlef Koschny.
Er ist das europäische Pendant
zu Rob Morgans Charakter.
Ihn habe ich gefragt,
wie man Kometen und Asteroiden
im Blick behält.
Es gibt im Moment
2 größere Surveys.
Das sind Überwachungsprogramme,
die den Himmel abscannen.
Jede klare Nacht versuchen sie
möglichst viel vom Himmel zu sehen.
Diese beiden Programme
sind von der NASA finanziert.
Mit der arbeiten wir eng zusammen.
Wenn sie ein neues Objekt entdecken,
muss man sofort schauen, wo es ist.
Ein paar Stunden später
muss man noch mal hinsehen.
Und ein paar Tage später wieder.
Das heißt: Follow-up-Beobachtungen.
Sie fragen, wie viele Objekte
noch zu entdecken sind.
Leider noch ziemlich viele.
Im Moment werden durchschnittlich
jede Nacht etwa 5 bis 7
von diesen "Near Earth Objects",
oder erdnahen Asteroiden entdeckt.
Die großen sind so wie
etwa die Dinosaurierkiller.
Damit haben wir keine Probleme.
Aber kleinere Objekte,
wenige Meter, 10 m oder 100 m groß,
da ist noch viel zu finden.
Halten wir fest:
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass so ein riesiger Komet
von über 5 km Durchmesser
aus dem Nichts auftaucht, ist etwa 0.
Aber es werden andauernd
neue Asteroiden und Kometen entdeckt.
Bei denen muss man auch prüfen,
ob die für uns gefährlich sind.
Das wird in den USA
am "Minor Planet Center" gemacht.
Dort müssen alle Sichtungen
solcher Objekte gemeldet werden.
Dieses Center berechnet dann,
ob der Komet oder Asteroid
der Erde jemals nah kommen wird.
Nah im astronomischen Sinne
heißt: unter 45 Mio. km.
Ein Asteroid, der von der Erde über 100-mal
weiter weg ist als der Mond,
gilt als erdnahes Objekt.
Nach der Distanzbestimmung
folgt der 2. Schritt.
Von einem anderen Institut,
wie der ESA,
wird die Flugbahn des Objektes
100 Jahre in die Zukunft berechnet.
Aus dieser Berechnung ergibt sich,
wie hoch das Risiko ist,
dass der Himmelskörper
mit der Erde kollidiert.
Es gibt 1.000 Asteroiden und Kometen,
für die das Risiko größer ist als 0.
Das ist aber kein Grund zur Sorge.
Von den 99,78% aus dem Film
sind wir real weit entfernt.
Das Objekt mit der größten
Einschlagwahrscheinlichkeit ist 10%.
Es ist aber nur ein paar Meter groß.
Da würde ich sogar hinfahren
und mir die Feuerkugel anschauen,
die man in der Atmosphäre sieht.
Die meisten Objekte liegen
bei kleinen Wahrscheinlichkeiten
von 1:10.000 und 1:100.000.
Was man aber vergleichen muss
mit anderen Sachen.
Für die meisten Objekte,
die wir auf der Risikoliste haben,
ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass sie die Erde treffen,
deutlich höher
als ein 6er im Lotto.
Es passiert auch ab und zu.
Wie 2013.
Da ist ein über 20 m großer Asteroid
in die Atmosphäre eingetreten
über Tscheljabinsk in Sibirien.
Er zerbrach dort in etwa 30 km Höhe.
Die Druckwelle,
die dabei entstand, war heftig.
Aus tausenden Gebäuden in der Region
wurden die Scheiben rausgehauen.
Über 1.500 Menschen wurden verletzt.
Statistisch betrachtet
kommt so etwas
alle paar Jahrzehnte auf die Erde.
Je größer die Objekte,
umso seltener ist es.
Bei 40 m Durchmesser
sind es 100 bis 1.000 Jahre.
Der letzte große Himmelskörper,
der mit der Erde kollidierte,
wie in "Don't Look Up",
war vor 66 Mio. Jahren.
Er fegte
die Dinosaurier von der Erde.
Nicht nur die,
sondern über die Hälfte aller Arten.
Bei "Don't Look Up" ist es gesetzt.
Der Komet ist da,
bewegt sich auf die Erde zu.
Er wird einschlagen
und hat die Zerstörungskraft
von 1 Mrd. Hiroshima-Bomben.
Es besteht eine 100% Chance,
dass wir alle sterben werden.
Der Menschheit muss
eine Lösung einfallen.
Es gibt in der realen Welt
verschiedene Szenarien,
wie man mit Himmelskörpern
auf Kollisionskurs umgeht,
sagt Detlef Koschny von der ESA.
Also kleiner als 50 m
würden wir nichts tun.
Da müsste man evakuieren.
Wir reden dann
mit Katastrophenschutzbehörden usw.
Größer als 50m: Wenn ich Asteroiden ablenken will,
gibt es verschiedene Techniken.
Das Eine nenne ich
kosmischer Auffahrunfall.
Ich habe einen Asteroiden
und schieße einen Satelliten
mit viel Geschwindigkeit
auf den Asteroiden drauf.
So wie wenn ich
auf ein anderes Auto drauf fahre.
Ich hoffe,
es ist Ihnen noch nie passiert.
Dann schiebe ich das
ein kleines bisschen nach vorne.
So einen kosmischen Auffahrunfall
will die NASA 2022 testen.
Vor ein paar Wochen
startete die DART-Mission ins All.
Die gleichnamige Sonde ist unterwegs
zu einem Gespann aus 2 Asteroiden.
Im September soll sie
in den kleineren Asteroiden fliegen,
um ihn aus seiner Bahn zu lenken.
Ob das geklappt hat, untersucht
die ESA in einer Folgemission.
Die startet 2024.
Das ist ein brutaler Ansatz.
Also reinballern, wegschubsen.
Das ist für mich das Spannende daran.
Es ist der 1. Versuch der Menschheit,
mit einem simplen Prinzip,
einen Asteroiden abzulenken.
Es gibt noch eine 2. Möglichkeit,
um Kometen oder Asteroiden
aus ihrer Bahn zu bewegen.
Die 2. Methode,
die ich für realistisch halte,
nennt sich "Gravity Tractor".
Da bringe ich
einen schweren Satelliten
in die Nähe des Asteroiden.
Die Anziehungskraft wirkt schwach,
sodass ich ein paar Jahre brauche.
Wenn ich den Abstand gleich halte,
kann ich den Asteroiden
aus seiner Bahn wegziehen.
Oder es gibt die Möglichkeit,
dass ich ihn
mit einem Ionen-Triebwerk bestrahle.
Dann puste ich den quasi weg.
Auch das dauert eine Weile.
Das sind realistische Verfahren,
die wir anwenden können.
Das ist krass.
Ein paar Jahre
müsste man das vorbereiten.
In "Don't Look Up"
hat die Menschheit 6 Monate Zeit.
Davon geht jede Menge drauf,
Politik, Medien und Allgemeinheit
davon zu überzeugen, dass es ein Problem gibt.
Zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt sollten wir
Ruhe bewahren und sondieren.
- Ruhe bewahren und sondieren.
- Ruhe bewahren und sondieren?
- Die Ruhe bewahren?
- Und dann sondieren.
5 Monate vor dem Einschlag
hat man dann doch einen Plan.
Man schickt einen Veteranen ins All,
bewaffnet mit Nuklearsprengköpfen.
Die sollen in die Nähe
des Kometen gebracht werden,
detonieren
und den Kometen aus der Bahn lenken.
Erst mal die Frage:
Kann ein Nuklearsprengstoff
so ein Objekt ablenken?
Das dürfte gehen.
Ich weiß es nicht sicher.
Denn die Kernexplosionstests
sind militärische Geschichten.
Militärische Sachen
erfahren wir leider nicht immer.
Wir hören auf Konferenzen Leuten zu,
die sich seit 30 Jahren
damit beschäftigen.
Die wissen mehr als wir.
Die sagen, macht euch keine Sorgen.
Das würden wir hinkriegen.
Dann zur Frage:
Wieviel Zeit brauche ich.
Also 5 Monate ist nicht viel.
Wir hatten im Frühjahr 2021
ein gespieltes Szenario.
Da ist ein etwas kleineres Objekt,
das war nicht 10 km groß,
vorhergesagt worden über Europa
in 6 Monaten.
Da wurde gesagt,
die einzige Möglichkeit
sind diese nuklearen Explosionen.
Am Schluss kam man aber drauf,
selbst das schaffen wir nicht
in diesem konkreten Fall.
Wie schwierig es wäre,
solche Manöver vorzubereiten,
könnt ihr selbst testen.
Die NASA hat eine App entwickelt,
in der man die Parameter
für simulierte Himmelskörper
selbst einstellen kann.
Da kann man etwa Umlaufbahn,
Durchmesser und Zusammensetzung
von einem Kollisionsobjekt verändern.
Dann kann man schauen,
wie viele Raketen man
mit wie viel Vorlauf schicken muss,
um den Einschlag zu verhindern.
Wenn ihr Bock habt
ein bisschen damit rumzuspielen,
schaut in die Infobox.
Da packe ich den Link hin.
Lasst eure Ergebnisse da,
als "Kometar".
Im Film wird der Plan
mit den Nuklearsprengköpfen
aus abstrusen Gründen verworfen.
Darauf möchte ich nicht eingehen.
Stattdessen versucht man den Kometen
in 30 kleinere Teile zu sprengen.
Diese sollen kontrolliert
über dem Meer abstürzen.
Ist so etwas denkbar?
Wenn ich in den Kometen reingehe
und da Explosionen mache,
kommt es auf dessen Eigenschaften an, ob der in 1.000 Stücke zerbricht.
Wenn das Kernexplosionen sind,
kommen die alle
radioaktiv verseucht
und dann doch vielleicht
irgendwo über Land runter.
Da würde ich denen im Film,
die die Entscheidung treffen,
dringend von abraten.
30 einzelne radioaktive Meteoriten,
die einen Durchmesser
von mehreren 100 m haben.
Das klingt nicht
nach einer wirklichen Alternative.
Mal abgesehen davon,
dass dieser Plan B
nur knapp vor dem Einschlag startet.
Da ist der Komet
schon am Nachthimmel zu sehen.
Wäre da irgendwas zu retten?
Bei einem Objekt von dieser Größe
können wir nichts machen.
Wenn der auf die Erde trifft,
hilft nur eins:
Auswandern,
auf den Mond oder Mars fliegen.
Wie die Sache im Film ausgeht,
spoilern wir nicht.
Das müsst ihr euch selbst anschauen.
"Don't Look Up"
ist zwar mehr Fiktion als Fakt.
Aber für die Starbesetzung
und für den schwarzen Humor
von Regisseur Adam McKay,
lohnt er sich allenfalls.
Ich habe ihn weniger
als Weltraumfilm verstanden,
sondern als Metapher
auf den Klimawandel.
Es gibt ein Problem,
das die Menschheit bedroht.
Die Politik ist träge
und die Allgemeinheit
ändert ihr Handeln nicht,
obwohl die Gefahr da ist.
Die hat im TV gemeint,
wir sterben alle.
- Nein.
* Jubel *
Wie habt ihr den Film verstanden?
Wie hat er euch gefallen?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Ich freue mich,
wenn ihr ein Abo dalasst
und die Glocke drückt.
Dann sehen wir uns bald wieder.
Bis dahin, ciao.
Copyright UT: MDR 2021
- Felix Sassmannshausen -